Startalk Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist this is a
special installment this is where we
take an in-depth look at the cosmos
possible world series episode by episode
and unpack some of the content that
you've seen I got with me Chuck nice
it's right who do just do this in front
of Heather Berlin a friend of Startalk
yeah thanks for coming back on brain
expert neuro neuro sure ready to talk
about episode 5 the connectome the
connector who were my new words at least
in my vocabulary in the connectome and
it's an entire episode that explores
basically the wiring of the brain yeah
but we do it through a story told by a
case where it's the first time I think
brain waves were ever measured hmm to
have some understanding that there's
something real going on in mind it's not
just whatever it is you think it is we
can measure it write something about it
yes and which we can it pivots on a
story of a boy who suffered from
epilepsy right so Heather could you just
update us well give us the foundation of
what epilepsy is and how people used to
think about it and how's this boy how's
he doing that how's the boy doing
he's 130 right okay I mean you know it's
many how far back you go right they used
to think it was you were possessed by
evil spirits you know and then and as
you say in the episode Hippocrates was
sort of one of the first people who said
no this is actually coming from the
brain called sacred disease right it was
interesting and yeah we're pretty sure
he was referencing epilepsy yeah he made
that reference yeah and then and then
you know went through a series but I
would say around like in the 1800's was
when they first realized this was a
brain disease and that it was come
from electrical you know problems with
the electrical activation let's say so
it'd have to be late enough in the 1800s
so that we'd have some sense of
electricity right so then to say hey
let's put this with that because the
physicists were were rapidly making
discoveries yeah Ben Franklin Moran of
Court made a lot of a guy progressive
progress in this he published a book
experimental researchers into
electricity
right so Europe knew him as a scientist
that's right we knew him as a as a well
we also know him as the science there's
a beer-drinking founding father we know
what was that Benjamin's there is no
reference to a science on that bill that
is truck just want you to know that is
true ok yes had that been in Europe they
would have had his kite his the key
absolute that lightning bolt they would
have stuff in I'm just saying yes yeah
they honor their scientist in deeper
ways than we do here yeah it's a great
example of how all the scientists are
interrelated exactly yeah when you make
a discovery in one fields it could have
implications at which II frog-leg yes
the Italian guy whose name is electrical
impulse and the nerves if they have
anything to do with each other at all
well yeah exactly
exactly sure his name begins with L
first name basis racist Ouija who Luigi
Galvani givanni nice cool all right and
then it was until the early 1900s where
we can actually measure the electrical
activity in the brain with the invention
of the EEG and so we still use that
technology today to diagnose epilepsy I
mean there's there's some you know other
ways that we can look at it but that is
sort of the gold standard still I mean
it's a more advanced EEG system but
we're so measuring
the electrical activity more advanced is
because we can measure now lower-level
activity or more precision or is our
ability to interpret better or we can
localize it in the brain better than all
these and then we combine that with
other with neuro imaging where we can
actually look inside the brain and look
juicy T scan or an MRI and to see if
there's any lesion in the brain that can
be let's say the focus of the epilepsy
so you have to know what the brain
should look like without the lesion
right so you have healthy controls and
take a look at your brain becomes a
facebook status now there are a number
of different causes some of them are
genetic you're born with it others are
what we call acquired meaning that if
you have so you get it later in life and
it could be related to having a lesion
in the brain a lot of brain trauma brain
trauma
we even see we can induce an up Litella
both epileptic seizure in surgery when
we are doing brain mapping so a person
is doing surgery let's say to remove a
tumor or to remove stock I just might
have to stop why would you want to an
accident so we're doing something else
in the brain so when we are people are
in surgery and we let's say we remove
removing a tumor or actually we're
removing part of the brain that's the
focus of the epileptic seizure because
that's sometimes a treatment to remove
where the seizure starts his name ben
Carson
Oh what does he have miss fear ectomy oh
man come to him no it was one of the
first he was one of the progenitors of
the hemispherectomy only in small
children finding that the brain could
recover if you removed large pieces of
it that the associations and the
workloads were distributed to other
parts of the brain that knits up the
slack okay Chuck that's why we have her
[Laughter]
we cut the corpus callosum which is the
connections between the two hemispheres
so if a seizure stored in one
atmospheric couldn't spread right over
okay so that's another option that was
the first one to measure right to
contain it exactly but now we can go in
and remove that if we find the focus
then we can remove that but during
surgery sometimes we want to make sure
if for example we don't remove the
language area of the brain so we do
electrical stimulation piece by piece
while the person is awake during surgery
and talk to them and make sure like
which part is involved in language it's
usually start messing up they can't
speak we like okay don't touch that part
but in the course of that but we do
these tiny sort electrical impulses but
sometimes that can trigger a seizure in
people so we can accidentally trigger
and not the full colonic time you know
where they're moving around many things
but we can see it via the electrical
activation
Oh basically is what it is is that the
neurons start firing in sync at the same
time which we don't want we want the
neurons to be evenly distributed because
then it becomes like brain noise right
if they're all if is it like a dislike
if everything's going at the same time
it's almost like your brain doesn't know
what to do yeah it's like
miscommunication so it's not
communicating in the right way and it's
problematic and not everybody has the
movement some people just have what we
call ops on seizures where they just
know to call absence ops which is like
absence but with a French accent when
you have a bowel movement
alright you got no more you go into the
baseball okay okay missing the
traditional motor cortex where they get
the full body movements which is what we
often think of what the seizure is a
different type of seizure but where they
suddenly can be talking and then just
lose consciously just stare off into
space for a few seconds and then
suddenly come back oh so he's a little
so it's like this seizure where the
brain activity is going but it's not
affecting the motor cortex and you just
suddenly become unconscious but your
eyes are open you start off into space
and you come back again so there are all
these different ways in which seizures
could occur they're all different types
of can you diagnose it today before
someone has ever had a seizure diagnosed
that they would or could have you know I
mean we could but normally we wouldn't
look in somebody who's never had a
seizure before for seizure activity so I
mean theoretically you could record then
see if a seizure happens to occur but
it's unlikely that we okay but also way
away but it also means you're missing
some data because the pre Marcy the pre
we're pretty morbid was I mean that
would be like the pre before the disease
it would morbid I don't know okay so it
seems to me that would or could be
highly useful to but you'd have to scan
so many and you don't know who the one
is gonna be and there's some genetic
link so maybe it runs in your family
you'd be more like oh yeah so let me ask
you this I have a friend who fell while
he was mountain biking okay
now he did not hit his head or maybe he
did and we're not sure he fell on his
back yeah okay and he fell on his spine
and then he started having kind of
alcohol the micro seizures but what
would happen is his leg would
involuntarily just kick right for no
reason at all and this went on for
months and the doctors were like hey man
you
damaged something we don't know exactly
what you damaged right and then after
about seven months and I'm talking about
every four or five minutes his leg would
just pick out just pick for no reason
and he went through life like that for
seven months and then it just went away
interesting I don't know if that was
seizure activity although you can fall
and not hit your head and the brain
shakes within the skull and then you can
get micro lesions in the white matter
which is the connectivity which might
have happened but it could just be a
basic motor problem it is okay my
diagnosis official so tell me about the
concept of the connectome right this is
we use the term in the in the in the in
the show and the show is very cosmos is
very forward-looking we'll take some
cutting-edge things and see what you
know how we can explore what that could
do for us so where's the connect state
of the connectome now well so the
connection is this idea if we can sort
of map out every connection in the human
brain sort of the way it's wired all the
wiring which is actually just a very
difficult task in and of itself so
there's a project called the Blue Brain
Project in the Sun and Switzerland run
by Henry Mac remand he's gotten like a
hundred billion or no not a hundred
billion I would say a billion euros to
do this and he spent one year euro per
neuron that's not because there's like
about 86 billion neurons and that's so
that's 1 billion dollars so if you do
the math it's yes yeah what's a
conversion
okay so it's a lot of money yeah a lot
of money a lot of any currency it's a
lot of money yes a lot of people a lot
of effort and and the most we could do
is sort of map out the specific
connections in one tiny little column
you know maybe sort of a millimeter of
cortex and so you can imagine doing this
over the entire brain it's a huge
project then the next question is we'd
get some information what you gonna do
with that right what do we do with that
information I mean obviously information
is good for you know for many things but
but that's so controversy in the field
about is it worth it to invest all this
money in this project in terms of like
what the benefits are when we could be
investing in I don't know you know
research and Alzheimers or whatever and
the idea is that theoretically this can
help with those endeavors
something yeah wiring to me is not the
same thing as what signals are going
over the wiring right that's the
activation okay so what does it mean to
have the wiring if you have no idea of
what the person is thinking all exactly
I mean so ultimately the first step is
to sort of get a map a brain map of all
the connections they don't by the way
all of our brains are different and and
also while our brains are active they
are changing the wiring in time so it's
not a static thing right so that's the
other issue so then like oh well we want
to map that plus function and then it
gets to be a very overwhelming difficult
learning money that people might want to
spend on other things even if even if
it's an objectively interesting topic
yeah the the fertility of the results
might not measure up to other places you
could be researched exactly like there
are other interesting yet for example
they're doing work at the Paul Allen
Brain Institute in Seattle where they're
looking at mapping the genome and seeing
how those the genes map out on to brain
development and you know looking at that
I think that could be more fruitful in
many ways but so so I think you know
their pluses and minuses with it it's
not it wouldn't say it's it's a it's a
bad endeavor but it's just a question of
resources how much we go this seems like
they should be spending money on better
ways of seeing into the brain right
because that will solve the issue that
you're talking about you know what it is
i right so it actually relates to some
of the things you often say about like
invested research in NASA because those
discoveries are going to be related to
other things so some of the research are
doing to figure out the connectome is
actually related to developing new
techniques to look into the brain and
look at it in a micro at the micro scale
these are the offers from that same line
of reasoning right so in that way that
is a benefit you didn't even see what's
coming there in front of you and it's
you know and by the way I mean that
could revolutionize it because let's say
for instance you come up with the means
of looking into the brain that is
democratized so that it's not as much
money to look into everybody's brain now
you can start to actually get a better
sense of what that map is and they also
have they actually have this video game
where people can play that adds the data
to it I think it's called like I
minecraft I'm pretty sure it's called my
crap
yeah so I think it has benefits and also
the other the other aspect of it is that
some people think ultimately if you can
like map out all the wiring of your
brain and download it somehow that would
like give you you know immortality which
I don't I don't buy that argument okay
so yeah okay so the real connectome
investors they want their stuff that's
what they like to preserve yeah that's
the you know there's this okay forget it
I'm getting ready to go on a head we got
to bring this to a close thank you for
being back on Startalk give us some
insight into epilepsy - by the way that
episode was one of the saddest for me
just thinking of the plight of the child
and they I remember just there's a lot
of sad stories in the episode yeah and
the patient who had the lesion yeah yeah
yeah just it was and he was the first
corridor yeah basically yeah yeah yeah
it's a repeated turn alright alright all
in going to take a break when we come
back we'll chat about episode 6 of
cosmos possible world on Startalk
we're back
sar talk and right now we're gonna talk
about episode 6 yes Chuck you were
saying you'd like that episode I did
very much yeah it's quite the profile of
Carl Sagan's role yeah Pauline figured
Sagan's role as a sight what impact he
had on the path that scientific research
took yeah coming out of the 1950's into
the 60s and right on up through the 70s
and 80s you know it's funny as Heather
brought it up in you know before we went
to break talking about how one
scientific discipline is connected to
another yes and that's the whole thing
with well if you don't know it is
because you were taught that here's your
geology book right and that that's that
book right now put that down and pick up
the biology book you know who's gonna
what that can't possibly leave you in a
good way to make cross-pollinated
connections yeah I mean I'll be there
yeah cross pollinated but like um man
who's your I see now so you have to
forgive me but he works here at the
museum with you and we were talking
about olivine and Halloween table yeah
it was the chair of the division of
physical sciences you're right and so
that's what he does he talks about the
formation of minerals in the in the
birthday in solar system right yeah yeah
but who would think that these so-called
rocks that we find here have a direct
connection to you know the cosmos in
whether physical phenomena stupid things
a phenomena thank you so so Carl Sagan I
think was one of the first you know
their turns we have today that we just
take for granted these are words stapled
together that you don't even hear as
stapled together anymore
okay so astrobiology asked us to
different see different fields coming
together you're two different
astrophysics that came first okay we got
that one right that's back at 18 I late
1800s right astral geologists
astrogeology bio geology all of these
terms are the tacit recognition that
creative juxtaposition of discoveries
can lead to a whole other discovery that
would otherwise
be completely impossible because nomen
stovepipe will ever go there right
that's what that is
so what do you think of the animations
yeah I loved it I mean what I like about
it is the fact that it brings me into
the story in ways I otherwise would not
be you know and sometimes I find myself
looking at the animation and going whoa
the thing is you know the the pedigree
of that animation comes from the fact
that Fox which was acquired the Fox
animation studios along with 20th
Century Fox and 21st Century Fox were
all acquired by Disney okay but they
were all under the same house in a
family that included National Geographic
so we have cosmos airing on National
Geographic in collaboration with Fox
talent that come from their Animation
Studios right so we didn't have to shop
hard to find people who would have the
talent to do this yes and what something
I always liked about the animation is if
you look at the facial expressions and
just gestures of the eyebrows and the
the cheeks there's very subtle movement
it speaks volumes it speaks volumes yeah
you're feeling the characters even
though they're like animated yeah you
know you think of animation you think of
like Bugs Bunny cartoons I'm not as a
serious medium to communicate historical
drama and so I said sometimes they'll do
something in the animation it I react to
it as if I'm watching people you know
the actual people I feel kind of silly
your kids laugh at you you know you know
and I also love seeing it makes the
scientists that are no longer here like
Piper like looking up at the sky as a
kid yeah and it brings you into it it's
like okay I get it now and he has really
good vision yeah yeah so you know I mean
I find that you know that's fascinating
one of the things I'm glad that such a
person who had really good vision became
an astral person that yeah because
because it makes sense yeah yeah yeah
think about it of the of your five
traditional senses mm-hmm vision is I'm
stating the obvious but it bears stating
your vision gives what what what's the
point of your senses they give us
information about the world around us so
that we can choose to interact in
whatever way is in the interest of our
survival okay that's what our sense is
do all right and so sight is the one
sense that can detect information about
an environment from the farthest
distance right okay that makes sense
okay because you can certainly see a
heck of a lot farther than you can hear
then you can hear okay or smell is
progressed and that was good but still
not as far right not enough nuts not
right you know maybe a dog dog dog dog
so but that's on earth but of course we
can take our sense of sight beyond Earth
right and the farthest thing you can see
with the unaided eye is the Andromeda
galaxy it's visible to the unaided eye
and it's 2 million light-years away
that's pretty servile alright so here's
kuiper with extraordinary acute sense of
sight and so I'm good with that
yes it's very cool so what I also found
interesting you know when they talk
about Carl Sagan is as I'm now of course
for me maybe other people aren't looking
at it like this when they're watching
the show mm-hmm because I know you I
know your story yeah so I'm looking at
this and I'm like here is the dude doing
cosmos who was actually mentored by the
dude who did cosmos to matter who's the
dude who's portrayed in the story right
exactly
it's super cool though I'm like looking
at you and I'm like people I don't I
don't you know I don't know if you want
to tell the story but you know your your
actual interaction and intersection with
Carl Sagan is pretty pretty cool story
well we told it in the in the cosmos
2014 but maybe not everyone saw that one
section of one episode of that series
six years
I'm happy to tell it again yeah we tell
me I think it's great and by the way I
think it's part of the entire profile of
his character yes and and now you broke
his heart it broke his heart man
no so I'm applying to colleges I'm in
high school here in New York City public
schools right and I'm and my application
is dripping with the universe right it's
dripping and I'm accepted at Cornell
University right but I don't know if I'm
gonna go yet because I have other I'm
waiting for other decisions that other
colleges and so so big brain problems
stop
big brain problems where should I do
Cornell yes Stan where I did not apply
to Stanford or Yale oh no you did not
want to have the Boris manners of a
Yalie you sound like Thurston Howell the
third who ever remembers that from from
Gilligan's Island he was a Harvard
person in it anyhow so unknown to me the
admissions office sent my application to
Carl Sagan he was already famous he
hadn't done cosmos yet but he was on The
Tonight Show and best-selling books and
I interviewed so he was already faint as
famous as any scientist had been you
know since probably since Einstein and
he did they sent my application to his
attention he wrote me a letter and let
it comes into mail and it's Carl and I'd
opened it up and it says hi I'm Carl
Sagan and I heard I just understand
you're thinking about colleges I do
astrophysics here and I bite you to come
visit to help you decide and let's just
let me know sign Carl that's amazing
sign Carl that's awesome
and I get the letter and it's like and
mom and daddy map deep dabbed at ed
should I go and I get and his New York
City he's an ethic of New York is it
five hour bus ride or so and so I
arranged the visit that we arranged
everything and I go and he meets me in
the front of his building there's on a
Saturday he's there
Wow okay and each taking his shows
giving me a tour of the lab and I'm in
his office and he said I'll never forget
this job I'm sitting across from his
desk
and he doesn't even look he reaches back
grabs a book as one of his books that he
wrote any luck yeah there's like the
no-look pass and basketball right he's a
NOLA grab just grab anything it's a book
he wrote anything behind me is something
I wrote okay pulls it out signs it to me
I still have that book okay sign to
kneel future astronomer okay
sorry Carl alright so see the sign to
intellectual gangsta because that is
Carl the gangster so but that's not
where it ended right so we're done any
walk outside it begins to snow as it
does so often anything without right on
and it's so it begins to snow it might
have been lake-effect snows I'm not sure
I love Lake effects shows yes here they
speak highly of you as well a will do an
info on lake effect snow yes it's a fun
concept but anyhow so I'm there and he
says he writes down here's my phone
number
it snows heavier and the bus can't get
through come spend the night with my
family and you leave tomorrow
this guy he's clearly saw something in
you well so here's the thing I and I had
people when I told to some people that
story they said you should have just
said the buster couldn't go through that
okay go have dinner with him and see if
library talk astrophysics so so the
point is to this day I treat other
students the way he treated me that's
very I mean if I'm at the desk and
that's the student comes by not gonna
and I'm I would say a Barak I'll got to
call you later I got a student coming in
I got a this exaggerated but only a
little bit right a little bit so I just
said to myself that's I have to be that
if I'm ever wear anywhere near that
otherwise what what am I doing here
so so this there's a passing of the
torch well I think he understood the
value of not only education in
general but the value of a mentor to a
student was that experience the single
greatest influence to causing you to
become now probably the world's most
renowned science communicator and I say
that objectively not as even though we
saw in your paycheck well yes and that's
why I had to say I said I could have a
bias just close the possible sources
Chuck is a wholly owned subsidiary of
stock radio so yes no no actually you
only partially owned you do well you got
your own that a little bunch of crap
which is always great so I would say it
influenced my influence what kind of a
scientist I would become hmm interesting
and I think back on and now now I'm
behind my desk and someone comes in
pardon me I learned this from Carl Sagan
who should I make this down so because I
as is clear from the story I already
knew I wanted to do astrophysics I'm
great really even before I knew of him
right so he wasn't he didn't influenced
my career arc he influenced my career
attitudes and perspectives oh and that's
important that's a shame that part of
the shape Club it has that part but the
other part you're talking about had
already lived form from the time you
were a kid all right
some people know what they want to do so
you know that's cool you told them no
you're not doing it you're not gonna
turn it right back and endorse to my
decision okay just so you know that's
cool okay so now what appear drops on
the on the thing but here's the deal
yeah irrespective of how great Harvard
might be
or any other institution to have
somebody of his prowess and stature to
reach out and invite you what was it
cuz I gotta know what would make you say
forget all that I gotta go over here
yeah yeah so I didn't care about
Harvard's legacy okay I still don't
really I don't I'm not into that so I'm
kind of with you on that because that
light doesn't wear Harvard ring I don't
wear it you know I don't ever legacies
are for other that's other people's
stuff
no a legacy is what people are so a
person wants if they themselves don't
have that's not so and you have your own
legacy you don't need a letter legacy is
the luminosity shed upon them by others
who've actually achieved things so
that's exactly what I meant but thanks
for making me look stupid City beaming
down and the others so I tried I don't
instead of radiation so you're wrong
yeah yeah I don't radiate your own damn
radiate your own life you don't worry
about being lipice I had nothing to do
with it what it was I wanna know yeah
tell you okay at the time I'm in middle
school and into high school I'd
subscribe to Scientific American and my
favorite part was a session called about
the authors and for every author even
the double authored papers
I picked everyone for that was on
astronomy and physics for every author I
made a grid of the colleges that had
accepted me and whether the author got
their undergraduate degree their masters
the PhD or where they were on the
faculty and for every one of them and I
made a checklist how old were you 16
okay so no know that I was applying to
college at 17 I'm 17
okay it's the same 60 and 70 right so
then I made this list and I put a check
for each of the schools that I was
accepted where all these people came
from I said if I'm gonna be a scientist
one day with the stature of who has been
vited to write for Scientific American
that's one of the hallmarks of
Scientific American actual scientists
write those articles but basically then
what is right so I put and it made the
list and then Harvard was like two or
three times longer on that grid than any
other
school I was accepted to Wow so I just
said that's that makes sense that bet
that's that's it and then I would later
learn that part of the reason why it was
so long is the Smithsonian Astrophysical
Observatory the government doing
astrophysics has their base co-located
with a Harvard College Observatory so so
there's a larger complex there of course
but so it but that's great right so
whatever my interests are there's gonna
be somebody in arm's reach that could
who can actually support it supports
support that interest Wow
so I made this list of what schools were
in state and basically would accept a
high C student
and by that I mean the Jews did you so
that's why so I I wanted to come up with
an objective measure that was not swayed
by any legacy or oh you but surely your
own hard work it's like no money balled
college acceptance that's pretty cool if
analysis is Moneyball then then let the
ball roll right on but anyhow so just to
close that out okay so we got Carl Sagan
Gerard Kuiper who later we credits the
naming of these all these objects in the
outer solar system Kuiper belt that's
right
where Pluto is found get over it
Pluto is the first and most prominent
member of the Kuiper belt to let you
know but but anyhow this just and the in
the episode we addressed some of the
tension that's between scientists and
the competitiveness I think if that's
kept in check it can be good to pump
your your your your your creative urges
to get ahead or just stay ahead but
anyhow I think it was a that episode had
to be in there just so you knew what
Carl Sagan's actual legacy would become
in this world I just love the fact that
you use this opportunity and Kuiper as a
means to throw shade on Pluto it's like
you kids you let me need me to throw
shade it's already so far out it lives
in shanxi where's the Sun
is that it over there but paw is that
the Sun so far away that he kicked Pluto
out of the Harvard club and put him in
the Friars play anyhow so we have a debt
of gratitude to Carl Sagan for 1/2
pioneering astrobiology for including
sort of biological using these
disciplines and bringing it to NASA to
help explore yeah this so all of that
they would all look very different were
it not for call landscape that's
excellent right
plus we wouldn't be here if he weren't
here either because he was in the first
episode that then became the next wooden
and third episode and I'm the host I
thought she was gonna say because he's
your father chocolate Carl is your
father that we start referencing star
wars it's time all right all right Chuck
we got in this episode that was just
episode six next week episodes 7 & 8
when we take a look and in-depth
behind-the-scenes discussion
[Applause]
you